みなさんこんにちは
今日はお招きいただきありがとうございますスピーカーのオーターまり子と申します
今日は出会いがてで x ユースの共通テーマということで私は好きからつながるで
好きという気持ちからつながる出会いじゃあすき家の表ペッツと言ってますが
例をご紹介していきたいと思ってます
まず私が何をやってご飯を食べている仕事をしてる人か
どんな経歴を持ってる人かというとあちなみにこれ私です
8友達のグラフィックデザインをやってる8グラフィックデザイナーの故に書いて
もらえますかねてる
8私今やっている仕事は都内のデザインスクールでファッションデザイナーになりたい
学生
この中で例えばテレビドラマのファーストクラスとカットしてるしています
見てるな女の子知ってるかもしれないねあのまああんな
0っていうかすごいあの色の人間模様ってわけではないけれどもファッションデザイン
を勉強したい
学生の今カリキュラムディレクターとしてどんなカリキュラムを組めばその学生が
ファッションデザイナーになれるのかということを日々研究しながら実践している講師
のハンティングだったり教材の作り方だったりあと買ってファッションショーをやっ
たりとか
展示会がたりだとかというのも私の仕事です
ねどっち大学に行ってその後はペッ末にベスティというニューヨークの大学でえっと
写真の勉強しました今日はみんなとずっと長い時間聞いているのであの教えたくないと
言うかもしれないんだけど私のプレゼンは写真がメインになっているのでぜひ見て誰も
せてください
今日みんなに伝えたいことは2つあります
この中で新郎が決まっている人はそんなにまだ多くはないかもしれないんですけれども
自分の進路を決めたい時とか何か重大な決断をしたい時にぜひこのマイムマップって
いうものを作ってみて下さい
マインドマップっていうのはどういうものかというと桜
えっ
自分の名前を中心にかけます私だったら私の名前をたマリコでそこから自分の興味関心
のあるものでのをどんどんどんどん考房で専乙前で書いてみる
でもなく頭に思い浮かんだジャストアイディアでもなんでもいいんですねこういった
ものを繋げていくとどこかでその点と点が結び合っ
たり関連性が持てたりあとは自分が線がいっぱい引き合っているところというのは自分
の興味関心が強い物好きという気持ちが強いものなんですね
この気持ちいいんじゃあスキャンハープ好きでしょうがないという意味の英語のマップ
いてもたってもいられないってくらい好きただちょっと好きて暗いと前で好きでしょう
がないということを選別するための頭の思考の整理方法です
なので今日私が伝えたい2つ目のことはこのすきでしょうが前と有機物をぜひ大事にし
てみんなこれから進路
を選んでほしいというようなことになります
ね私がこの前のマップを作ったときにじゃあ自分興味何話をするにあたって自分何が
好きでしょうがないのかなって思うと
いままでやってきたことだったり考えるとファッション
度教育っていうこの3.22
絞り込まれることが整理していてわかりました
でそれについて私が今までやってきたことをちょっと話していきたいとおもいます
まずた日ですけど出汁と大学生の頃から初めて
バックパックで世界20カ国ぐらいに旅をしたことがあります
今からいろんな旅の写真をちょっとエピソードも末でて話していければと思っても
ん
さっき者スキャナ caps キーの気持ちを大事にしてねっていうのお話だと思うん
ですけれども面白いと思うこととか
面白そスキーだなあこれと思うことはぜひ旅先でも日本でもみんなも学校生活の中でも
やって欲しくって
これ
スカイダイビングですねスカイダイビングって地上からだいたいまあ少なくとも
1000メートル1キロぐらいのところからあの飛行機からポンって放り出されるん
ですけどそれをチャレンジしたりとか
これはメキシコの丘から見える風景です
一人で行った食べもあったし4人くらいで食べもあります
これ私が留学をしていた new
これはイタリアの-3-5
やっぱり好きなものデザインされているものとかすごく好きなのでこういった物にも目
が向きます
ねえっとインドにはに書いたことがあってすごく人口密度の高くて面白い国です
私が旅をするときに気をつけていたのは現地の人と極力同じようなものを食べて同じ
ような生活をして同じような交通手段を使って旅をするということになる
なので彼はと結構本鳥肌も誓ってすごい高
あの距離感も近くて写真も全部これを今紹介するの音仕事とさせになるんですけど良い
撮影がいっぱい撮れましたこれはエンドって逆算たっていうの形をしていてそのあの
一番町店というか一番南の最南端のところでカニャクマリて美咲があるんですけどここ
は巡礼の地としてすごく有名で朝3時ぐらいからバスでいろんな人たちがインド各地
からこう集まってくるんですね
でみんなで朝日を見るっていうほんとあの宗教の一つですけどそういったものにも参加
をしてみも不当
これは砂漠モロッコ
米もう一つメジャー試験ヘアペルスキーの木持つよう大事にして私が今までやってきた
ことの一つはファッションでえっとこれはまルーツがあって私親がファッション
デザイナーをへと東京でずっとやっていて小さいころからまあお洋服
もうどんなタイプの今日みたいなデニムニットを着ている日もあればキレイ
まあケースを着る日もありまふ生ファッションてもの着るものは好きでした
で今これ実際に私と私のチームが手掛けている
ば少々になるんですけれどもニューヨークであの学生デザイナーの作品を発表するため
のショー
企画梅をしたりしています
ねまぁ少々をやるって言ってもただ服を着てモデルさんがラーメンを歩けば終わりと
いうわけではなくて
下準備がすごくもうほんと半年暗い一つのショーをやるのに必要になってくるんですね
a もちろん服を作るっていうのもあの
準備の大変な1つではありますけれどもそれを宣伝していく材料を取るために
の写真撮影シューティングがあったりとかあとはこういったメイクのテストをやって
たりだとか
こういったモデルさんも当日だけくるのではなくって事前に来てもらってリハーサルを
やったり
もうした準備としてこの服を着ましょうねというようなミーティングを捨てたリアと
かっていうのもやっていきます
なので今日のてデックスもいろんな人たちが協力してくれていろんなスタ準備があって
行われているものですけれどもファッションショーもそういったもので非常に
準備が必要
こういったモデルサウンダ誰を使うかっていうのを選んでいた家とかというのがみんな
なかなかファッションの仕事であんまりこう
イメージがわかないかもしれないけれどもたさせることをしています
もう一つは教育雑誌が好きなもの
とさっき色んな国の写真を撮っていく中で一つ気づいたことが私すごく子供のさせんが
多いなって思ったんですね
でまぁ大学一年生くらいのときから度はずっとしていたのでそれを持って大学3年生の
時にあの教育のサークルを仲間と一緒に立ち上げましたこれが
あこれインドの子だね a 棟
カンボジアで
英語大カンボジアの子供たちに教えるというサークルを大学3年生の時に立ち上げまし
た
でみんなちょっとビックリするかもしれないけどカンボジアの小学校中学校というのは
理科の実験とか美術とか
体育とか音楽とか一切ないんですねでもう全部あの先生がこう
を
書くものを
番匠場所したものをノートに撮るだけ暗記するっていうのが向こうのメインの授業に
なるんです
なのでもっと面白いこうワクワクする好きという気持ちを伝えたいというのが私の
ちょっとライフワークの一つでもあるので
理科の実験をやっぱりとかあこれ solive 作ってるところですね結構みんな小
学校とかでスライムとかつけると思うんだけど
もうカボチャの子たちは中学生高校するもやったことがないので本当に楽しそうにやっ
てくれますと
たくさん村でというのを私のライフワークにしています
で今そのデザインスクールで学生を持っている立場でもあるのでその日々
学生に何が多く学生のためになるのかっていうのを気をつけながら勉強を重ねて
カリキュラムを作ってるっていうのが私の今やっていることになります
ん
なのでここで皆さんに伝えておきた今日は非常に貴重なバーを頂いたので
8私が皆さんに伝えたいのは何か自分の進路を作る時
たぶんすごく迷ったりとかすると思うんですね例えば親からはこういうふうにしろって
言われたとか
周りはこっちに何学部にから僕も私
も何学部に行こうかなとかいろんな悩みがあると思うんだけどそのときに1回頭を
ちょっと整理してみてほしいで全部自分の頭の中のものを紙に書きだして
で自分を中心において自分中心に置いてそこから自分の興味関心のあるものだけを
たくさんかきだしてください
も何でも構わない例えばザーっ英語が好きとか
私の声も好きですけど英語が好きとか語学が好きとか数学が好きとか言えなくたって別
にいいと思うんですね
例えば音楽が好き歌うことが好きだったらそれをとことん極めてくださいね例えば
ミュージシャンになれなくても
音楽を売り出すプロデュースしていくビジネスに乗せていく人たちだっています
出崎ず日はゲームが好きってなったらゲームゲームプログラマーになるという道もあり
ます
でも同じくゲームを軌道に乗せていくビジネスに乗せていくプロデューサーの人たち
そしてそれを売り出す場所を作る展示会を作る人たち
展示会を作るその大工さんだったりとか空間プロデューサーだったり空間デザインの
っていうのもお仕事としては存在しています
なので自分が今と心のどこかにちょっとこれ好きだなやってみたいなって思うものを
どんどんどんどん高校生の時には膨らませるようにして言ってほしいんですね
そこには必ず仕事が付いてくるから
でそれを今私もラッキーなことに
ファッションデザインというのと教育っていうのともちろんインターナショナルである
ということを仕事にできています
なので絶対あきらめないでほしい例えば世の中にはこれとこれしか職業がないんだ今
思ってる職業のた分で1000倍ぐらいに夜中には職業というものがあります
なので自分が好きって思うものを学生のうちにはこの蛇スキャナやペン付きでしょうが
ないって位の気持ちのものをどんどん追いかけてください
そしたらその先に必ずあなたがそれでご飯を食べていける道っていうのはあるはずです
私今日を伝えていきたかったことはマインドマップを作って吹きでしょうかな女子形の
ヘアオペと言えるような気持ちを追い求めてほしいっていうようなことでした
ご静聴ありがとうございました
ああああああ